i
uh had no idea that i was going to be
talking to so many people
i luckily i don't get more nervous in
front of 1100 than in front of 200 or
something
that but it is a surprise and it's a a
beautiful venue
and uh and uh it's exciting and it's an
honor to
to be here um and it's
you know of course to have a conference
named something that a phrase that you
once invented
40 years ago or something like that is
is is a very
it's a very curious thing uh and uh
it's an honor and it's and it's and it's
a pleasure and i can
tell that i would have a great deal in
common with many many of the people
here uh too bad there's you know
time is finite and life is fine
um i wanted to say that
i i i accepted the invitation for
a number of reasons but one was the name
of the conference but
another was that alex wrote me a
handwritten letter
and it was he he gave it to dan friedman
who many of you know
i think one of you must know dan
friedman particularly well
if you're here dan and
uh and uh dan said doug i have something
to give you
uh and so i went over to his house and
he gave me the letter and i saw the
invitation and one
you'd receive a hand written letter like
that so graciously inviting you to a
conference
with the name of following something
that you've invented it's hard to turn
it down
and so so it was it was a very nice
thing
i might also say that dan played another
role i mean i've known dan for a long
time because we're both
at indiana university and he was one of
the main reasons that i went to
iu back in 1977
but uh in 1979 godaleshire bach came
out and dan threw a party for
the uh appearance of ged i mean and you
you know what was wonderful about it in
retrospect
or at the time it was already wonderful
that he did such a nice thing
because just to throw a party for the
launching of a book is very nice but
the point is that it was not a known
book it wasn't known that it was going
to become
famous or that it would win a pulitzer
prize or anything like that dan just did
it because he loved the book from having
seen a pre-publication
version he just was excited so that was
marvelous
and then he threw another party in 1999
on the 20th anniversary of the book and
again it was a marvelous party at his
house so i mean
you know dan and i go back long ways and
strange loops
and such things and so i i just wanted
to give a little bit of background to
some of my connections here i mean i
could go on and on
but i think i better get to the point of
my
the central point of my talk which is to
talk about this notion of of strange
loops in my view of it which uh is
it's a term that i invented uh i
sometimes regret having invented it but
that's okay um you know you you invent
an idea and it goes out into the
world and people interpret it in their
own ways and you
contribute in many ways to its
misinterpretation
uh by not being clear enough uh you
being me in this case
and um you're not always me but in this
particular case you are
and uh so
so uh uh
i as a as a youngster or a teenager
i have always i was always interested in
what it is that gives
us a self or a soul or a consciousness
or an
eye and
and that was what led to my writing
good leisherbach and my placing the
notion of strange loops at its core
although i don't think that was well
understood at the time
when the book came out and i i think
it's my fault i probably didn't state it
enough or clearly enough or whatever
so in about some i don't know when it
was
almost 30 years later i came out with
this book i
am a strange loop which in which i tried
to say these things again but
to put the emphasis more on what i was
trying to say
in a philosophical sense and um
i found that my ideas had probably
developed somewhat in the interim they
hadn't i hadn't changed them but i had
increased them and so i was able to say
them in new ways and
and so that's what that's what happened
so i begin this book by talking about
my own reverence you might say
for life um and uh
and and the fact that i've been a
vegetarian for a long time i've
you know gone back and forth drawing
them my threshold for where
i i mean for a while i ate um
chicken and turkey and fish and then i
didn't and then i did again and
you know so i i've sort of waffled a
little bit about where the line is
uh and i um and that's in itself a very
interesting matter it brings up
questions of course about what it is
that creates
respect for us for other beings
and when do we think other beings merit
a certain kind of uh respect for you
could say that they have a soul
or they have a self or they are
conscious
or they have feelings or they have
experiences
where is the borderline between
small things and big things and it's not
exactly a small big thing but it tends
to be correlated that way for example
why am i as a vegetarian perfectly okay
with
swatting a mosquito that sounds like a
sort of a
simple-minded question but the point is
i'm not okay
in general with uh killing insects i
tend to respect insects to the extent
that i can without i mean i
if i by accident you know in the shower
see that a spider is going down the
drain i
think oh my gosh too bad but
you know i you know i don't i don't uh
you know turned out
turn off the plumbing system in my house
and try to take the pipes apart
to recogni to rescue this spider i mean
but there is a certain reverence
nonetheless
for life but not it doesn't extend you
know
it's not as much reverence for for
spiders or ants
or mosquitoes as it is for let's say
a squirrel and then
more much more for a dog and
and and so forth up the scale to humans
and uh so what is the difference what is
going on and i might i want to extend
the continuum or
maybe continue isn't exactly the right
word but
i want to also bring into the picture
some other kinds of structures
uh let me include i'll i'll say along
the continuum
below the level of mosquitoes uh
thermostats
and below that level although it's
valley probably at the same level uh
flush toilets
um and i would also include in there
somewhere and i don't know quite where
uh plants um so
you know that's
it's something to think about if you've
ever watched time lapse photography
of plants uh moving around and
sort of groping grasping seeking things
in in their environment it looks eerily
much like the tentacles of an octopus
or something like that and it makes you
really
wonder how much uh awareness if you
want to use that word there is in the
fiber of a plant um things to think
about
uh very very provocative questions
so um so to jump to the
uh to the uh the punchline so to speak
or the
the point is that i think that what
makes me
feel that something re is worthy of
respect
is when it houses a strange loop
a strange loop of a certain sort i might
say because
in my books i've tended to use the word
strange loop to talk about things that i
don't think i
even i would qualify as being conscious
um so i have to say a certain
type of strange loop and i want to just
sketch that out for you
a little bit um in this uh in this short
period
so we begin with the
concept of perception it's very crucial
um that we talk about perception because
that's where
every where it all comes from what is
perception
um i'm not going to give you a
dictionary definition or a rigorous
definition but i want to just suggest it
um and i think you'll probably agree
with me that
perception is a kind of funneling
process
and by which if you take human
perception we
[Music]
perceive something in the outside world
that is it impinges upon us in some
fashion
the most obvious fashion being through
light impinging on
our eyes and then it excites
processes further back in the brain
until
at some point it triggers the
um the uh a concept
so that we can label something so i can
label this a book
i can label this thing a podium i can
label that big thing out there
an audience and so forth and so on
i've never seen this audience before but
i can still do it
which says that i don't pay attention to
all the fine-grained details
it's a coarse-grained approximation
summarizing
these i don't know maybe it's eleven
hundred people
each of whom is a very complex entity uh
and taking a multiplying a complex
entity by eleven hundred and then just
reducing it down to one thing and saying
this is an audience
is obviously throwing away an enormous
amount of information not to mention all
the visual signals all the photons
reaching my eye
and all the neural firings on my retina
that are
all going down and being funneled down
into that just
one word audience uh so i want you to
think of
of of perception as being an extreme
funneling operation and um
uh so it perception exists
uh in all living beings
in various forms and there are different
uh levels of sophistication
of perception and i think this is
self-evident
i'm going to let me if we talk about a
mosquito for example
what kinds of things can a mosquito
perceive
i don't think that if a mosquito were
flying around in here that it would
perceive
an audience uh i don't think it would
perceive
a podium what i think it would perceive
is
some warmth and
in a certain sense uh a source of
nutrition although it doesn't
it wouldn't have that concept uh the way
we do
nutrition or food or anything like that
um
it might also perceive uh from time to
time or maybe very often
landing spots and it i don't think it
has
you know in any sense a uh
it's very subtle to try to put words on
these things but i
i would i would i would like to say and
i don't know if you'll agree with this
intuition that i i think a mosquito is
such a primitive being
that it doesn't really have the concept
of landing spot
or the concept of food or nutrition
or anything like that to make to give
you a sense of that
i mean i don't think my knee has the
concept of
anything when it you know when i hit the
right spot and it jerks
it just does it it's a living thing
but it doesn't have concepts and it
doesn't need concepts to have reflexes
and i think a mosquito is at about that
level
now if you were to if you were to go
down to a more primitive level
such as that of a flush toilet
a flush toilet perceives
some aspect of the world and makes
decisions you might
say i mean in a very crude sense
it perceives if you allow me to use that
word perceive
it perceives the water level and
it says yes or no i will add some more
water
if the water level is high enough it
says no and if the water level is low it
says
yes and uh and so the
the uh but it doesn't have the concept
of high or low or enough
or water or anything like that it
manages to do these things without those
concepts
and it's in that sense i think that's a
good metaphor for thinking
and the knee maybe might be helpful too
for thinking
about um about how a mosquito can
can react to the world in a conceptless
way uh but nonetheless
by in a certain sense by perceiving
certain things
and it makes uh it makes sort of yes no
decisions land here or not
um on the basis of a certain amount of
information that is impinging on it
which is much bigger than one bit i mean
it's all those photons
that are impinging on it that allow it
to decide whether or not to land or it's
all those vibrations you know the the
the molecules in the air that are
banging into it that create the feeling
of a temperature gradient that suggests
oh yes i think i'll go this way and i
will stan
stop here and i will now try to get some
blood although it doesn't have the
concept of blood either
so um so
perception is a funneling process
and it exists sometimes with concepts
and sometimes without concepts and i'm
not going to suggest
that the boundary line is iron clad that
is that all of a sudden at a certain
level of
sophistication concepts snap into
existence
um it's more that as
creatures become
deal with a more complex environment and
have more complex behaviors
their the
the structures the the neural structures
get more and more complex
and the neural networks get more and
more intricate
and gradually concept-like things start
to emerge very primitive ones
and so it might even be that maybe
something inside the mosquito's brain
does deserve to be considered a very
primitive concept
in that case all the things that i said
you just have to reduce it to a simpler
creature
um i i mean i'm just pointing out that
there's a continuum it's not
a black and white on or off phenomenon
now as creatures get more and more
sophisticated and have higher and higher
degrees of sophistication in their
conceptual repertoires
they um well they
they perceive the environment they they
divide it up into finer and finer
categories
and more and more abstract categories
their categories don't always have to
depend upon instant visual or auditory
or tactile
input in other words we categorize
humans categorize things
on the basis of hearing stories you know
you say um somebody tells you a story
and say
oh yeah yeah yeah that's just sour
grapes
and it's a category you didn't see
anything you didn't i mean you heard
something but it's not because
it's not you're categorizing the sound
that the all the vibrations the fourier
series the
the as as sour grapes you're talking
about
a situation that you perceived thanks to
those sign
those sound waves you perceived an
abstract situation in some far
part of the world involving people that
you've never met
and you said ah yeah just sour grapes
and
and so we have very sophisticated
perceptions that take place
and as i say once again think of how
much of a condensation or compression
or funneling act that is where a whole
story that could have taken somebody 10
minutes to recount
gets reduced down into the two word
phrase
sour grapes
so we have these very sophisticated
perception
mechanisms now what
in one's environment is going to be
perceived the most and the most often
and the most in greatest detail
i think the answer is probably very
self-evident that is it's the things one
encounters the most
that is the most frequent things are
going to have the most frequent
perception
now uh in the case
that means that means basically since i
am around myself more often than i'm
around anything
else that means i perceive myself
more often than i perceive anything else
and so
my conceptual my my perception of myself
is going to be very sophisticated and
it's going to involve a very large
set of concepts
and you might wonder about whether
mosquitoes have therefore a very large
conceptual repertoire i would again
remind you that
uh it depends on the level of perceptual
sophistication i mean for example if you
take a
uh a uh
a thermostat or a flush
toilet they don't perceive themselves
thermostat perceives the temperature and
that's all
a flush toilet perceives the water level
that's all
and the mechanism itself made out of
metal or plastic or whatever
does not perceive itself um
you have to have a a fairly
sophisticated level of perception in
order to start
um focusing your perception back on
yourself
now when i say focusing perception back
on yourself
i don't mean um
that uh necessarily that you are are
looking at yourself although certainly
that's part of it i mean i can look
at my hand and say that's that's me and
i can get
some impression about my
five-fingeredness
and so forth um but uh i mean
that's certainly part of it um but
uh in the case of human beings
we have perception that goes way
beyond the visual way beyond the
auditory way beyond the tactical
tactile maybe at the very beginning of
our
um you know in our childhood in our
early childhood
i mean very early most much of it is
hearing one's own voice or seeing one's
own hand
but very soon after
we are beyond that stage at age one or
two maybe
we start to get feedback from the
environment
about our nature um
oh doug he's so cute oh dougie's so
smart
oh dougie's so stubborn uh or whatever i
mean
you know so i start to formulate
uh or maybe just uh
internalize what other people tell me
but in any case i start to have a
self-image about
my properties and
as time goes on my
image becomes very sophisticated
um and i start to be aware of
all sorts of things about myself that
uh that are discoveries
and that start accumulating or accreting
and forming this complex structure that
is my
self-image i might mention that i don't
know a year or so ago i saw some
dismissive comment by a well-known
neuroscientist
um about i'm a strange loop but it was
obvious that he hadn't read the book
it was it was clear that he he was
saying hofstadter's concept of strange
loop has nothing to do with
consciousness and then he
said what he thought my concept was
and i want to i can't quote it because i
don't remember exactly but
basically he said it was something like
it's when a thinking being thinks about
itself thinking about itself thinking
about itself thinking about itself
thinking about itself thinking about
itself etc etc
and he said that's ridiculous that has
nothing to do with what consciousness is
and i would agree
that's a if if you want to posit such a
a state of mind
um maybe you know we enter such states
of mind uh
on very very very rare occasions if
we're inclined towards being
philosophical or if we're inclined
towards
zen buddhism or taoism or something like
that
but most of us never think of anything
like that and
um and uh and we're perfectly conscious
to the extent that anything is conscious
in a certain sense i also
maintain in the book that consciousness
is an illusion but
it's it's a kind of a balancing act it
depends on what one means by what is
real and what is
not real so if i say that consciousness
is real
if i say if i attribute it to human
beings then it's certainly not
because of the fact that they think
about themselves thinking about
themselves thinking about themselves
like the
um in the hotel that i'm in
the hilton maybe some of you are in
there too and then you go in the
elevator it reflects back and forth
millions of times well not millions but
you can see you know images going down
many times and it's amusing but uh
but it's it's sort of just a triviality
what i mean by self-perception
is uh is not just the idea of
this kind of super zen buddhist
kind of thing or whatever you want to
call it i mean
the self-perception that we all build up
of ourselves
over life that tells us who we are in
this world
what we are like what kind of person are
we
um for example um i i learned that i was
pretty good at math
when i was um you know in
in say junior high school or high school
and then um that was a very intense part
of my self-image
when i hit math graduate school i hit
what i called
i i described it in the book here uh an
abstraction ceiling and uh
and it was a very unpleasant experience
it was about as
unpleasant as hitting myself you know
when you stand up and there's a
open cupboard and you stand up quickly
and it hurts like hell well it's how it
felt
hitting my abstraction ceiling uh except
that the abstraction ceiling was
inside my head because it was a property
of my brain
that i had never suspected i had always
thought i was really really good at math
and i found out that while
there comes a point in math where i tune
out
can't grasp this stuff anymore it's too
hard
and it really was almost instantaneous
and uh and it hurt a lot and i it forced
me to change my life's pathway i
i had to get out of math and so that was
a learning
experience about myself it told me i'm
pretty good at math but i'm not so good
as i thought
and um and likewise uh
we learn about our skill in all sorts of
things uh our skill level
in all sorts of things and we learn
about i mean i've i've been told
by friends things like
oh i have a tendency to make certain
kinds of jokes
or certain kinds of puns and so i become
aware of that and i internalize
that or um it goes on and on and on i
mean
our self-image is built up of uh
of you know millions
of experiences like that some of it is
direct feedback from what people tell
us some of it is feedback from seeing
ourself in the mirror
some of it is from watching videos of
ourselves
some of it is in in reviews that people
write of the books we write
and on and on and on so
uh and and some of it is being spanked
by your parents
i mean it it includes all sorts of types
of
uh of feedback but it builds up
and accretes and becomes a a
a very important central part of
our decision making function and now i
want to talk a little bit about this
idea of causality
um i think it's important to try to
think about causality
uh so let me let me give you let me
switch wavelength for a more switch
whatever you switch channels gears um
and and give you a hypothetical story
how many minutes do i have by the way
alex
or somebody just so i know where i am
10 15 10 more
20. okay um
so uh i want you to imagine
uh the country of france i want you to
imagine it as a as a being that's
telling it's
it's it's it's story it's life so to
speak
so it's going to tell you about the wars
it had with germany and with england and
with other countries
and what vocabulary is it going to use
it's going to talk about
such things as well germany for example
it'll talk about germany it'll talk
about
italy and spain and england it'll talk
about the atlantic ocean
it'll talk about um maybe it'll talk
about the
uh the the rhone river or the luar
maybe if it's a smart france let's give
it some credit maybe it'll talk about
paris it's unlikely to be able to talk
about little tiny towns because it'll
never have heard of them
and it help will certainly never have
heard of any of the people who live in
it
they're invisible they're too small
um so it knows nothing of napoleon
nothing of de gaulle uh and nothing of
people from any other country it knows
nothing of hitler
but it knows it had a big war with
germany and that some property
was taken from one country and given to
another country
and uh and such things but
there's a level below which it simply
cannot peer
and so france will say and so i decided
to do this
you know whatever it might be i don't
know some decision in a war or something
um and at at some point
you know some french general or emperor
or
president or whatever you want to say
says
you france what are you talking about i
decided it
i made that decision napoleon says i
decided to
invade russia you france you just
followed along i mean i conveyed this
decision to my generals and they
conveyed it to their subordinates and
they conveyed it down to the soldiers
and then we marched in i made the
decision france didn't make the decision
what is this nonsense
uh france doesn't ever make decisions
but france doesn't know about
napoleon france doesn't know anything
about people
and so france attributes the causality
to itself on its own level
and it says that's what i decided to do
and it's perfectly happy doing so
and it gets along very well uh in
in talking about things at this level
so this is a metaphor of course but i i
think it's
important because um it's
obviously meant to suggest to you the
analogous thing about ourselves
now i don't maintain that there is a
napoleon
neuron in my brain that if only i knew
it
uh you know it would tell me i decided
to do that i decided to call it strange
loop
or i decided to write good lecture
neurons
on their own don't
have that causal they're they they can't
make such big decisions
um i mean they're more like thermostats
or or flush toilets
there or or or knee jerk reflexes but
um the thing is though that the
the uh the way things happen
in the brain is that's where the
the true physical causality is taking
place
to attribute um causality
to an ethereal thing like an i
is a kind of a mistake in other words if
i say
um i decide to pick up this book that's
pretty weird because it sounds as if
some
airy fairy thing some immaterial thing
is making things move in this world
what's really going on is stuff at
a physical level is pushing around other
things
at a physical level and a nice
summary for that is um
is you know it's convenient just as it
would be convenient for france to say i
decided to invite invade russia
it's convenient uh for us to be able to
say i decided to pick up the book
but uh the question is to what extent is
this i
thing real if you talk about
if you want to talk about causality and
talk about what is real
you can talk about macroscopic things
for example
if um if
if we're if somebody hits a home run
they hit the ball out of the ballpark we
don't
need to resort to description of the
event
at the level of particles or atoms or
something like that because classical
physics applies
well to macroscopic objects as long as
they
are fairly simple in in structure
i mean you can't really explain the
entire behavior
of of a country in a war
using classical physics but you can
certainly uh explain the behavior of a
baseball when hit by a bat
using newtonian mechanics and it works
very well
and so in that sense the ball is a real
thing the bat
is a real thing the contact between them
is a real thing and it's all
the explanation at the macroscopic level
is
is a very very reliable thing and
because it's so
extraordinarily reliable it becomes very
real to us
on the other hand um things like i
are far less
reliable less predictable which is why
people
often are so tempted to talk about free
will
they want to say that there is free will
and i
just decide whatever i want and then
as a function of that the world follows
that is
i decide let's see uh i think i will no
i won't yes yes i will i will pick it up
and and and the i decided it and that's
what happened
free will uh decided where
these all these molecules this two-pound
object
where it moved how did free will push
that two pound object around
well in this book i talk about that
somewhat and um i
i just subtract four letters from that
eight letter expression
free will i take out the first four i'm
happy with
will just not happy with free
so let me take an example from today i
was driving over from
bloomington indiana and uh
and you know i'd stop for gas at some
point and i pulled in and i saw that
i was at a place where there's some you
know they
sell snacks as they do at most gas
stations
and there was inside me a part of me
that was a little bit hungry that wanted
some potato chips
and there was another part of me inside
me
that said come on you've been gaining
weight recently
no potato chips and there was a little
tussle
between these two forces inside of me
as there is every time i think about
eating potato chips incidentally
and in fact as there is any time i think
about eating anything
and um and
so what happened in the case today was
that the potato chip side won
i did i bought the potato chips now
um you might so
what i would say is today why did that
happen
why did that happen i can give you sort
of an explanation uh
that is i would say that um
the uh it's a function of
how hungry i am the fact that i had
stopped at a gas station if i hadn't
stopped at a gas station i wouldn't have
pulled over in order to get some potato
chips but i there i was i was already
sort of almost there and then there was
a question of what about the other side
was it how active was my upsetness about
my gaining weight today this morning
and it wasn't too upset i figured i
wasn't going to have any lunch today
and so okay i could indulge myself with
a little package of potato
chips as a matter of fact to be very
honest there were two
sizes of bags in different places and i
picked up one bag and i looked at and i
said that's too big i don't want to eat
that much
so i was about to say no potato chips
today and then i remembered there was
another place so i walked over to the
other place and i saw a little bag and i
said okay
that one's okay so you can see that
there was a a play of forces going on
inside my brain there's no
freedom here there are different forces
interacting and on
different days the forces have different
strengths
on one day maybe someday i'll look at
myself in the mirror and say ugh
and the next day i won't get any potato
chips and
on some other day i'll look at my weight
on the scale
and i'll say wow i'm really pretty low
that's good
and i'll get let myself get the potato
chips this is not
free will this is just different factors
having different
strengths on different days and there's
a
tussle and the stronger side wins
it's very simple it's there's nothing
free here
now you might say well what is the what
are these will things aren't they as
as uh as airy fairy as
i well they're a little simpler than i
because um a desire is
is is not as complex the desire for
potato chips is not as complex as the
entire
image of myself and my in my
that has built up over all of my life
a desire for potato chips or a desire to
lose weight are much simpler
things they are still very complex
things inside my brain
and no doubt about it and and to try to
describe those in terms of neurons would
be very difficult
um and beyond you know anybody's
conceivability at this time but what i
am trying to say is we can
we can imagine how inside the brain
there is a set of forces of things
moving around
in some sense uh fights taking place
that are explanatory
and that are more close to the physical
level
than just saying i and attributing free
will to it
um and uh it's not as it's not as
physical as
the ball hit out of the ballpark by the
bat you know where you can take the
velocity of the ball and the velocity of
the bat and
things like that and calculate how far
it'll go that's a very
very classical physics thing whereas
the things about desires and fighting
desires are far from the world of
classical physics
but my point is you can imagine moving
downwards
towards that and seeing that there is a
tale to be told at different levels of
description
and that as you go the tail gets more
and more
deterministic or scientific if you wish
as you get lower and lower in terms of
the the or smaller and smaller more and
more microscopic and so
what is real is microscopic
and what is sort of an airy fairy thing
is is is not only is you couldn't even
say i is macroscopic because that would
imply it has a size
i is this vague blurry thing
that we don't we just think of it as
immaterial
um and uh so
it it's it's it's you know it's
analogous to what i was saying about
france
um that is france says i decided
and and the story is much better told at
a different level
at the level of people making decisions
than at the level of
the country making decisions but it's
very convenient
um okay so the
strange loop notion is
this idea that
we need in order to survive in this
world we need to perceive things
in a very simplified way that is i have
to see an audience
rather than the billions or trillions of
photons or neural firings retinal
firings
i have to be able to summarize this very
rapidly
in order to make decisions about what to
do
in in my life obviously in evolutionary
terms i have to
make decisions about fight versus flight
for example but it goes
at much more sophisticated levels than
just fight versus flight
in any case i you have to be able to
size things up
rapidly and that means funneling down
uh from billions or trillions of pieces
of input
incredibly rapidly into just a decision
oh that person looks nice
yeah i think i can trust them or i don't
trust that person
things like that we have to make these
decisions very very rapidly
by the seat of our pants and um and
that's
needed and so we have to believe
in the reality we're forced to believe
in the reality of these things that are
that we think we perceive and um
we may be dimly aware that there's some
other level of reality
down there below that but we ignore it
because we can't afford to think about
it we have to think about it at this
other level
so our our perception of ourself like
this hypothetical francis perception of
itself
takes or not only of of ourself but also
of other people and of other things that
is
france's perception of germany france's
perception
of the atlantic ocean uh france's
perception of the alps and so forth
is um all of these things uh
are are funneling down they're very
simple very simple
simplified um
representations of these things france's
par
france's representation of paris will be
a drastic
uh simplification of what paris really
is
paris is a teething a seething
metropolis
uh filled with um
people and france doesn't know about
people uh
and so it it knows that paris has a
river running through it and that
that you know i don't know i don't know
what it would know about paris i mean
this is all hypothetical anyway but uh
the same thing like me and my kidney i
don't know much about my kidneys i sort
of dimly know i have a kidney
that's about it or two kidneys and i
don't know what they do really
and i could read about it if i wanted to
but i don't need to know
um i uh and
so self-perception is is interesting
because we assign
causality to uh airy fairy things
um that uh and it and it is necessary
for us to do that
and yet the real causality in the case
of
a very complex thing like france or a
human being
is really not taking place at that level
i've sort of talked about the real
causality of why i bought the potato
chips today and i suggested that
the real causality is at the level of
will
that is desire of this versus the desire
of that but even those things
are too complex um in a certain sense
because
will or a desire is
too airy fairy in ocean also
and so really the fight takes place even
at
a more at a more physical and a more
microscopic level than that
but we're getting closer to the real
causality
when we go down further and i remind you
this is in contrast
to the baseball case where we don't need
to go down to the atoms or the molecules
inside the baseball in the bat
because classical physics does a fine
job
but classical physics doesn't do a fine
job
in in explaining the brain i i'm not
saying it's quantum mechanical
if what i'm saying is there are too many
things the brain can be perfectly
classical
but you can't handle 10 to the 30th
particles
simultaneously you can't use classical
physics classical physics is not cut out
to have 10 to the 30th equations being
solved
in parallel so we can't use the
techniques of classical physics to
predict
anything so we wind up with
um with a a a kind of a
a a way of looking at the world where
what we see
is a drastically simplified picture of
the world
which works to some degree but where the
actual causality
resides on a different level
i'll finish up with one exam one image
that is often used as an example of a
strange loop and i want to
talk about how it's different from a
real strange loop and that'll
be a good closing point on the cover of
my book
i have a picture of video feedback and
probably many of you have experimented
with video feedback where you point
the television camera at the television
screen
that it is the image of the television
screen goes onto the screen
and so then it because it's a recursive
process then you have a screen inside a
screen inside a screen inside a screen
and and it it can be fascinating and you
can get wonderful phenomena
uh i won't go into it because i don't
have the time but even just such a
simple act as tilting the camera a
little bit
will tilt the first screen which will
tilt the second screen which will tilt
the third screen and you'll get a spiral
which is what is on the cover here um uh
so you get amazingly complex and
wonderful phenomena coming out of this
kind of self-referential act of pointing
what seems to be a perceptual
apparatus at itself that is having it do
self-perception
what i want to do is i want to dispel
the notion that it is self-perception
it is no is there's no perception going
on here and this is where it's different
from a strange
loop and this is the crucial difference
as i said
and i tried to make very clear
perception is a funneling process
whereby a fantastically complex
set of stimuli is reduced
drastically down not always into a word
but at least into a concept so in the
case of
my looking out here and saying there's
an audience it's a word
or if i hear a story and i say sour
grapes
it's a two-word phrase or sometimes
it'll be something that doesn't have a
name i'll just
hear a story and i'll be reminded
of another story and i'll say oh yeah
that happened just
same thing happened to me and so what
i'm perceiving is
something that has no name but an
abstract essence of a story
that already happened to me in a very
different way
at some other time so concepts sometimes
are labeled sometimes with one word
sometimes with two
sometimes not even at all but in any
case
when i perceive something whether it's a
an
object or a vast thing like an audience
or
a civil war or a store funny story or a
joke
that i'm told concepts are triggered
and uh this is
the funneling act that is
the crux of perception and nothing like
that
is going on in the case of a video
feedback loop
it's a loop for sure you might think
it's strange because you're doing this
kind of closing the circuit
there is a strangeness there but it's
not that
what i meant when i invented the term
strange loop what i meant
was a kind of self-perception where
what you perceive is this there's a
drastic
over simplifi not over a drastic
simplification
going on in everything you perceive so
that when i build myself
model it's it it's a ridiculous
over simple well there may be
oversimplification is correct
in any case it's it's a it's it's a
ridiculous compression
uh it it um if i say
about myself i hit my abstraction
ceiling that's a ridiculous
uh it's not ridiculous but it's it's an
incredible
uh reduction of complexity of something
that was very complex
something that's almost indescribable uh
hitting one's abstraction
ceiling but it's what i say and it's my
way of understanding my own
experience at age 21 or 22 when i did
that
and um and and so that is the kind of
thing that i'm talking about when i
refer to self-perception
and it's necessary for us to perceive
ourselves
in order to survive in the world it's
necessary for us to make these drastic
uh reductions these drastic compressions
throwing away things uh you know factors
of millions or billions
in terms of complexity that's what
allows us to survive
in real time but it gives us a very
a very uh partial obviously
truth about the world just as it would
give france
only a partial truth if it said i
decided to invade
russia so our self-image
is based on this notion of our i
as a causal agent when in fact the truth
is that the causality lies at a
completely different level
but we are prevented from seeing that
because we cannot see those little
things going on inside of us
and so our image our
our entire way of conceiving ourselves
is based on this drastic
oversimplification
which is just a story we tell ourselves
and the degree to which this notion
called i is real is debatable
and uh i to use the word i
i'm inclined to think that it is
a mirage it's more like a rainbow
let's say or a mirage let's use the word
rainbow
um a rainbow is in a certain sense a
real thing
but it's not real in the sense in the
same sense as
a book it's it's a it's a far
um hazier uh vaguer
thing and i think we have to think of uh
i
as being as maybe less
real than a rainbow no matter how
compelling it is
and we have to realize that i is just a
shorthand
for something else that is too complex
for us
to understand and so that's where this
idea of strange loops is what it's all
about
and thank you for listening